[Music]
get ready swifties because your wildest
dreams are about to come true
literally i'm so excited on friday
taylor swift unexpectedly dropped her
re-recorded version of wildest dreams
after the original version of the song
blew up on tick-tock thanks to the
popular slow zoom trend using the
singer's popular ballad naturally i had
to give it a shot
[Music]
the singer shared the news on her insta
story friday writing quote hi i saw you
guys got wildest dreams trending on tick
tock thought you should have my version
i'm just here to have fun taylor also
posted about it on tick tock captioning
her video of the re-released single
offer 1989 album quote someone said slow
zoom makes you look like the main
character i said make it taylor's
version please
[Music]
in just one hour the video was shared
almost 12 000 times and accumulated
almost 350
000 likes how'd i do that she later got
in on the trend herself posting this
clip with the re-recorded version of
course
[Music]
but swifties know before taylor decided
to surprise fans with wildest streams
off her 1989 album she was busy
promoting the re-recording of red which
is slated for a november 19th release
and according to taylor the album's
release will be the first time fans will
get to hear all 30 songs that were meant
to go on the album one of the tracks is
reportedly 10 minutes long which fans
speculate is fan favorite all too well
you never know what it's going to be
fans will recall that the 31 year old
musician decided to re-record her
masters after a dispute with her former
record label big machine taylor's
decision to re-record her first six
albums came after it was announced that
justin bieber's manager scooter braun
who taylor accused of quote bullying her
had purchased big machine and along with
it her masters and while it hasn't been
confirmed when 1989 will be re-recorded
and released we have wildest dreams to
get us
[Music]
you'll through me
[Music]